[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash we keep it
moving
we keeps it moving and I washed my hair
and it is looking fluffy as [ __ ] I'm
coming to Memphis Tennessee
follow the leader tour is coming to
Chattanooga Knoxville and Hoover Alabama
and and Tarrytown New York and Atlantic
City now here's what's up I have a live
app and I have a live app and I posted
on my my live app that I'm going live on
my show and what happens is when I get a
phone call it stops recording and then
what happens is I have to rerecord it so
right now it's had stopped and I have to
reroute I have to rego and the reason is
cuz Bryan Callen called me now this is
what's [ __ ] annoying about Bryan
Callen okay he asked me to get together
to do this thing for him to try it like
this video for him and I said to him I
can't and now that's the end of that now
instead of that he called me because he
thinks he's gonna be like what about if
we do and I said I can't and that's it
so Bryan Callen this episode is for you
go [ __ ] yourself don't call me when I'm
in the middle of some [ __ ] and I said I
can't okay
we love you Bryan Callen but right now
you know sometimes when you when you
love somebody to go through some [ __ ]
and you're just like you know what
they're pissing me off and now that's
what's pissing me off cuz let me tell
you why
Bryan Callen is enough
one person that's hard to get on the
phone or hard to text so I got these
shoes that this guy made
Cody Cody look here Cody Cody the
creative The Brink's where he made these
shoes these congratulations shoes where
he got these Jordan ones and this is
what he does you can make back and make
these shoes and he made these he
custom-made these shoes for me backing
up the Brinks and it's got money on the
back here and then the Brinks logo on
the tongue which is [ __ ] funny and he
brought him to the comedy store and gave
them to me and that's pretty cool so
we're gonna keep these here in the
studio keeping it real we gotta keep it
very real here so that's what what the
[ __ ] dude but here's the thing about
what I've been feeling is it's it we're
in LA and it hasn't been hot yet it just
hasn't been hot yeah it's been hot for
like one day or two days maybe two days
at a time and it's it's not it's not
getting there and it's [ __ ] June it's
mid June already right yeah so let's get
it going dude I came to LA I live in LA
I want it to be hot as [ __ ] but my hair
is washed it's fluffy as [ __ ] dude
I get that good that's this if I here's
the deal now this is very important
because this is a very important thing
to talk about I know you guys are really
really really uh wondering this a lot of
times people like oh you don't wash your
hair because they think they're funny
because I have long hair and a scraggly
beard and I got to be like oh yeah I
wash my hair and when I wash my hair the
next day it's banging dude it is over
when I wash my hair the next day it's
banging especially if I wash my hair
then work out I have a light workout a
little bit of a perspiration and have
beads of sweat driven down my body like
I'm in a [ __ ] Omarion video and then
I [ __ ] go to sleep and then wake up
that's it dude don't bring your girl
around me especially if if I [ __ ] wash
my hair and then worked out and then
went just leave and then walk out that's
it
yeah III I don't know it's just uh it's
it's it's it's episode 125 and this is
what I want to look up though this is
the thing that made me laugh it's been a
while since I've laughed this hard bro
so the Toronto Raptors won
congratulations to run a Raptors love
Kauai very cool it was hilarious how he
he won the game and then still would
wouldn't wouldn't be excited until he
got to do his free throw because he was
fouled at set Kauai but then when they
won Drake Drake hey Drake I love Drake
you you you're not on the team okay
you're just not on the team now when you
give post interviews you're on the team
right so what the [ __ ] the deal I get
he's a major I appeal or like wasn't
even [ __ ] interview him dude he's
right okay but dude this interview was
the best
the six and six what does that mean six
in six so six the six which is Toronto
in six games right that's what they want
okay quiet Leonard bringing a chip to
this city now all now it now now what we
know right there is you lost all the
dads we don't know you know if you're a
dad you don't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about right you're just like Kay
well what does that mean bring you
brought a chip to the city I'm out okay
if my dad was listening to this he'll be
like woola's that you get chips when you
win okay I don't want my I want two
chips with the dead I don't want my
chips playing I want my chips with the
dead so dude that's what he was saying
okay I don't know what he means do you
know what he means getting a chip ma is
that money I don't here we go
[Music]
dude my favorite thing is to think of
Drake being like here we go he's walking
through the thing and he's like here we
go I see the [ __ ] guys and with all
the microphones and everything like that
and I and I like to imagine he was like
I'm gonna do my chips thing like on the
way to the game he was like if they win
I'm gonna do that chips with the dip
thing like he's just with this girl or
with some homies and he's just like
driving to the game being driven to the
game and they're like yo Drake just
maybe the [ __ ] this may be the time
where they went and they haven't won in
a while and he'll be like yup they're
like they're gonna obviously interview
you he's like yeah and he's like what
you gonna say he's like I got it all
sorted no worry I got it all sorted cuz
you know they brought a chip to the city
if they went right and the dudes were
like oh yeah and they don't know but
they're saying yes because they're in
Drake's camp and you don't say no to
Drake and he was like yeah you're like
alright well I'm just gonna MIT I'm just
gonna go on like this did this chips run
you know well I say how he brought a
chip to the city and I'm gonna start
talking about it and they're like yeah
that's right that's dope dog and then he
[ __ ] came up and did this [ __ ]
[Music]
I know
you know what's funny is - so to bring
them tips so bring them tips dude you
know what's funny is - and I made a
[ __ ] meme of it and I made the first
one and then people [ __ ] kind of
ripped it all off and [ __ ] and about the
[ __ ] I said hello welcome to
Applebee's can I take your order
and then he [ __ ] can I have it
welcome to Applebee's Kennedy ordered
[Music]
dude it's so it's either he set it up
but I don't think actually he decided on
saying it while he was driving to the
[ __ ] game I think it took him
off-guard and he was like they brought a
chip to the city and since you know his
music is like so like you know in rap
there's so many metaphors and he's like
a pretty [ __ ] hardcore metaphor guy
and so he was like he said the chips
thing and then he was like I want my
chips with the dip and then there's a
little flicker of like oh I don't know
what the [ __ ] this wasn't the best
analogy but what I really like about
Drake is he doesn't back down he said I
don't want my chips plane
I want my chips with the dip and then
further furthered it and said so bring
them dips which was just in [ __ ]
incredible dude I'm on my chips with the
dip that's all I know so bring them dips
oh my god dude I know so bring them dips
and then dude wow what a kawaii why does
kawaii look like you just watched
[ __ ] seven documentaries in a row
always looks like he just watched like
like seven hardcore documentaries where
everyone gets cancer and he's just like
- there was a meme where he was where
they took a picture of him and he was
like and everyone was cheering everyone
was like excited that they won the
championship and his face was just
chilling and then and somebody wrote man
kawaii just are already forgot that he
want but like he's so in his head dude
but dude god bless
[Music]
let's see how it keeps you
maybe
and the big mommy
[Music]
you know what it means
did he just talk he ever know what he's
saying what does it mean it's not about
what it means what do you mean dude it's
not about what it means
he brought a chip to the city dude of
course it's about what it means
he's just so amped you know what's funny
is all the fame all the [ __ ] money
all the [ __ ] like your inner dork will
always shine through you know and
everybody has some sort of version of
their inner dork but it always will come
out if you're too excited I don't know
what mine is mine is not basketball for
sure but it's so funny dude I guess the
championship is a chip I want my chip I
don't know what it means people on my
app are like chips means championship I
[ __ ] love Drake dude that new song
with Chris Brown who beats the [ __ ] on a
woman that that [ __ ] song it's ok
everyone's talking about is the new
anthem of the summer and it's ok it's ok
but also [ __ ] OJ's on Twitter which
is crazy and how many followers does OJ
have on Twitter like the fact that he
has a knee is bad if you follow Oh J on
Twitter chu doon like what are you doing
dude he has I always pull up the wrong
one how about fake accounts dude this
[ __ ] kills me when somebody like I
saw a guy Torry doing it the other day
and I like I like a Tory but he was like
he was like yo like how many followers
his guy Torry have on Instagram he's
like a comedian he's got so many
followers and then like these this is
you you know who usually does this is
Instagram models because they're not
famous but they want to be and part of
being famous is having like dummy
accounts so if a girl has like two
hundred and forty five thousand
followers they'll be like this is a fake
account it's not me and that that one
has like five account five followers and
they're like just so you know if this
one is not
like of course is not you the real one
has [ __ ] 2400 and [ __ ] million
followers but guy Torry dead and I was
like guy Torry um how many followers is
OJ Simpson half debbie hilarious have
twitter verified him you know six
hundred and fifty seven thousand
followers dude that's [ __ ] six
hundred and fifty seven thousand people
who are like I we know you killed that
we know you killed those people but [ __ ]
it I'll throw you follow you know how
[ __ ] disrespect that is that's so
shitty like what are you doing dude and
he was saying Twitter the world is yours
truly now coming soon the Twitter you'll
get this every time I hear Oh Jay
Simpson like I don't hear him that much
and then like a year later his voice is
so much more his voice the world like
hate or the world is yours truly now
coming soon to Twitter you'll get to
read all my thoughts and opinions on
just about everything
now there's a lot of fake oj accounts
out there so this one at the real oj 32
is the only official one so it should be
a lot of fun I got a little getting even
to do hey I got a little again even to
do a Hello Twitter world it's OJ
Simpson's all efficient solar official
account is a lot of fake ones out there
why does he turn into a [ __ ] old I
mean he said well this is yours truly
now coming soon the Twitter you'll get
to read all my thoughts and opinions on
just about everything just about
everything like how black eyes are
[ __ ] so young-looking until one day
they just look 90 for 50 years right
dude if you see a black guy he could be
[ __ ] for real 12 or 40 and then one
day it's like when they hit 50 that's it
there Morgan Freeman for 50 years and
then you're just
no note or twirl Hey
you killed two people a lot of fake oj
accounts out there so this one at the
reload j32 is the only official one so I
want to know god damn I want to know how
he's how is he doing that
of course [ __ ] Theo follows him well
man I don't know maybe he didn't do it
you know there's a there's a [ __ ] I
believe in our court system you know
maybe he here's the thing about OJ's
there's a [ __ ] thing about how his he
was thought he was caught he was
covering up for his son that's the only
conspiracy theory that's like oh that
[ __ ] because you believe a father would
do that for our son
and he'll never admit it right but OJ
was supremely jealous and definitely
probably killed those people so it's all
good
so it's all good hello toward world I
feel like any year he's gonna be like
hello and then in [ __ ] five years is
gonna be like oh um I can't like what is
this world the fact that OJ Simpson is
on Twitter it says everything is a South
Park episode
well my chips who did bit spring them
oops
well my chips with the dips on my chips
I don't want to wait it regular chips
want them chips with the dip I measure
all the people like this is like the
karma guys I don't know
hey dude the world is nuts like people
thought like when Bieber challenged Tom
Cruise to the fight like everyone was
like oh what the [ __ ]
and then Bieber was like yo I'm joking
and everyone I mean no [ __ ] he's joking
man no [ __ ]
he's joking Bieber's like yeah yeah you
[ __ ] you you you want to fight or
you're scared
you think [ __ ] talk you think Tom
Cruise would have beat up Justin Bieber
I think just be able to beat the [ __ ]
out of him people are like yeah you
don't [ __ ] with Tom Cruise oh he does
all his own stunts and he's always
running I think we would have beat the
[ __ ] out of Tom Cruise and dude Bieber
would have beat the [ __ ] out of Tom
Cruise for real he's twenty zero and Tom
Cruise is fifty whatever and Tom Cruise
would have would have would have
sincerely lost and they would have
interviewed him after the fight and they
are depending on people who and he would
have been like Oh bleep you see we have
a responsibility it's not just the
warnings it's not just Davis cabbage you
know it's not just not just me it's fro
I've watched that 75 times is the last
time we talked about it my favorite is
when he's like this my favorite this is
my favorite is when he goes like this in
the end of it they get this clip of him
just going like this and he's just like
and he does this he does like what a
[ __ ] straight up guy who's just knows
he's killing at life and he's just like
and he's got his one ring finger in his
mouth and his other pinky is just and
he's just and his two hands are up on
the temple dude if you're doing that
you're this dude he was gone you guys
like this imagine doing that that's some
[ __ ]
dude if you put your [ __ ] two fingers
up to your temple and your one finger in
your mouth
imagine this because some of you guys
are just listening to this and then your
little pinky is just dangling dude you
got your two [ __ ] fingers on your
temple imagine this one your ring finger
I'm touching your bottom teeth and then
your [ __ ] pinky is just dangling dude
you cannot be more confident than that
you simply can't that part is so [ __ ]
ill there it is it's so ill I got to get
to that point
where you're just [ __ ] laughing about
life that's what I love about Tom Cruise
that he laughed so much because his life
is this [ __ ] his life is a [ __ ] are
depending on us the way for me cuz I'm
just it doesn't make me feel loved we
have more work I need more help get
those spectators you're in the playing
fields is that of the arena this is the
guy I want to beat understand that's how
I feel I do what I can you know Tom
Cruise is saying for real this is his
version of I want my chips with the bit
and I do it the way I do it everything
sit not funny but there's nothing part
of the way for me I just and just die
endowed that you don't understand you
don't understand to it people think that
like Drake and like these famous
people's in telling they just there
that's my goal is to get there dude is
to get to the point where I'm just and
oh by the way I'm not that famous but
I'm almost there
I'm the regular guy almost there that's
just like I'm on my chips with the dead
dude I want to go to meetings and being
like well you know I want my chips with
the dirt and just laughing like a
[ __ ] dude of a [ __ ] that's not
funny but I don't give a [ __ ] cuz I'm
killing it that's that's how you that's
how we all have to get dude if we aren't
all there then life is just gonna
[ __ ] crumble do it we're gonna build
these bombs we're gonna build these
[ __ ] the cities are gonna get too big
people are gonna hate each other dude
that's the goal to get there dude
to get there I talked about this is a
theme on this on this on this on this
podcast but it's the goal dude I mean
couldn't Tarantino's probably like this
I don't know this is Tom Hardy Tom Hardy
talking about somebody asked him about
asexuality celebrities to talk about
their sexuality I don't find it
difficult for celebrities to talk about
their sexuality are you asking me about
my sexuality oh wow just good actors in
real life act better than anything in
the world you want about but what is
your question I was wondering if you
find it difficult for celebrities to
talk about their sexuality I don't find
it difficult for celebrities to talk
about their sexuality are you asking me
about my sexuality I'll get the guy
crumbles okay why slammed thank you okay
yeah that's so annoying dude that people
want to know if somebody's gay or not or
whatever I would never tell anybody if
I'm straight or gay ever in my life if
somebody came up to me if I hope I get
famous enough to where people are just
like hey Chris what's up with your
sexuality I go like this not talent not
Talent maybe I [ __ ] maybe I make love
to women and maybe I [ __ ] dudes all day
long I never tell you
we need a straight guy to be straight
secretly and never talk about his
sexuality and be like now I would never
talk to you about my sexual I'm not I'm
not telling you and then we find out
later he's married with kids it was like
Oh though we thought you were hiding
that you were gay he's like why my
sexuality is none of your business I'm a
straight guy and I got
I'm married but I never would admit that
because it doesn't [ __ ] matter
slammed them this is a Hollywood
celebrity shutting down reporters you
Robert Downey jr. are the reason I'm
asking about the past
is that you you've talks in other
interviews again about your relationship
with your father and you can see he's
already steaming the dark periods you
enters and taking drugs and drinking and
all of that and I just wondered whether
you know you think you're free of all of
that or whether that's still some sorry
I really don't know what are we doing
well I'm just asking questions that's
all right by man just saying bye you
know he should only afford one that's
what you should do when somebody asked
questions you don't want you looking for
we go like this and don't even say
anything and just wave your hand in
their face imagine if you just saw
somebody like Sam Jackson just oh yeah I
would like to talk about and he just
doesn't ain't just goes until and is it
what are you doing
and you saw and then just get up and
leave you just [ __ ] a wave in their
face huh for [ __ ] sake do it I gotta
get so [ __ ] famous so I could do [ __ ]
like that you don't understand dude I'm
telling you right now that's what I'm
doing dude I can't [ __ ] wait you know
what the [ __ ] worst name is Hieu
straight up the worst name on the planet
is Hugh do you know why it's but you
it's not even a [ __ ] it's like a
sound you can basically say the name
Hugh without even using your voice
that's the name that name [ __ ] sucks
dude Hugh Hugh
hey what's up my name's you alright here
we go
farmers dog dog food companies love use
fancy fancy recipe names and colorful
pictures of meat of real meat and
veggies on the back but it seems no
matter the brand or the price or the
ingredients on the label all you find
inside are unidentified dried-out brown
nuggets why do we accept this is food
right let alone as healthy food I mean
they're for dogs we wouldn't eat that
stuff for ourselves so why would you
want to treat your dogs the same way
beef and carrots what kind of that those
items could sit on a shelf for months or
even years come on guys introducing
farmers dog the company helping dogs
live longer healthier lives by making it
easy and convenient to feed them fresh
food the recipes are made fresh and
delivered directly to your door and
meals arrived in pre-portioned easy to
serve packs and because they're
delivered by a subscription you'll
always have food on hand I've done it my
dogs love it they gobble it up so so so
fast and they're happy and I love my dog
so much it's done because clever
marketing has convinced pet owners to
equate unhealthy and highly processed
kibble with food but unlike kibble the
farmers dog actually looks and smells
like real food because it is real food
start feeding your dog better today get
50% off your two-week trial of fresh
healthy food at the farmer's dog calm /
Congrats plus you'll get free shipping
just go to the farmers dog dot-com /
congrats to get 50% off your two-week
trial that's the farmers dog com /
Congrats go easy Jordans off whites if
you're going to buy sneakers for a few
hundred dollars which I do because I'm
an addict Missha by an addict how can
you be sure that the real thing
goat calm is the safest way to buy and
sell authentic sneakers online they're
the largest marketplace in the world for
authentic Yeezys Jordans and over
600,000 sneaker listings they made the
whole process frictionless and
trustworthy they do this they only
accept the the sellers with the best
reputation and you know how you go on
Amazon you say
oh we you know I want to know if this
this product is is is legit that they do
this but they do it even better they
verify all sneakers to ensure their
authenticity for the buyers because they
get shipped the sneaker and then they
inspect it and then they send it out so
it's not like it gets shipped right to
you it's awesome it's awesome
it's all inspected every detail find the
perfect 100% authentic sneaker at Goat
calm / congrats with over half a million
sneakers on the platform and 10 million
users I'm one of those you won't find
better prices for verified 100%
authentic sneakers anywhere else
that's Goat calm / Congrats plus you'll
also be supporting our show but you've
got to go right now before the sneakers
you want are gone when you go to go calm
/ Congrats that geo a t.com / of
Congrats
well my chips with the Det so I know
when the chips with the dip if my name
is Hugh and my family and they me Hugh a
second I grew up my first orders will be
like watchin Amy here celebrities get
nuts that's why I don't understand like
I'm already nuts I'm not as famous as
these guys I'm talking about
I'm already nuts I know if I forget to
the level of like Harrison Ford dude I'm
straight up I'm just gonna wear a shirt
around that's it no pants no nothing
just just a long shirt and sometimes
it'll like flap up and you see my dick
and balls and [ __ ] and and I'll get
arrested and I'll be like we shouldn't
wouldn't have to wear pants to society
who cares it'll be like whoa Chris Lee
is [ __ ] crazy I'll be like you saw
this [ __ ] come on [ __ ] look at
the catalogues of congratulations but
that's the thing when you like when you
look at somebody like Keanu Reeves it
which is like just unbelievable how
amazing he stayed positive how do you
stay positive
how do you stay like we don't know much
about calories but we know every time
you hear about Kennedy's
it's of him doing the nicest thing like
people will be like yeah my dog's County
Reeves [ __ ] literally jumped in front
of a moving train to save my dog or
Kenny's yeah dude I was talking to
counter Reeves and I mentioned he you
know I mentioned I need like some
[ __ ] blood transfusion and he
straight-up drove me to the hospital and
he gave me some blood I guess it comes
from him not you know what comes from
and for sure him not having a Twitter
Instagram account he's had an Instagram
or Twitter it'd be over you get if you
have a Twitter and Instagram you can get
canceled you know but if you don't you
kind of can I mean you can but not
really though because Sean Connery
doesn't have this [ __ ] and you're all
the [ __ ] he said I people were tweeting
about that [ __ ] they didn't have a
Twitter account have a Twitter or an
Instagram people think they can't like
write to you so they're like oh he's not
gonna see it I think they do it when
they're like this mother because my mode
Sean Connery said about like you you
should slap women ha
and then he doubled down on it he was
having an interview and I was like so
you said you should slap women he's like
yes I think I think that you should I
was like well I don't like that very
much as I will sometimes I reckon up
worst worst on a [ __ ] impression ever
but like he and and then and then like
people were like we got to cancel him
and then it came out on Twitter a little
bit but then he doesn't have a Twitter
so people are like a [ __ ] it boy he's
not gonna he's old he's old I got to get
rid of my [ __ ] that's the thing I kind
of get to the point where you look at
output that's the thing I always talk
about this it's like Al Pacino in
someone you become undirected in your
own life that's what it is if you're not
with a [ __ ] hardcore if you don't
have somebody that grounds you in a real
way you go you're done you go crazy like
you need a wife or a [ __ ] real person
that can just bring that's what that's
why that's where actors get so bad
that's why you're like what the [ __ ]
happened to that actor used to be so
good now look what the [ __ ] he's doing
because he was in he got too much of an
ego and then he started being in movies
and the directors could
hold him down that's why every now and
then Al Pacino has a movie where he's
just you're like what the [ __ ] is he
doing he still kills it I mean he's
still brilliant and [ __ ] as an actor
connectors even really brilliant you
know but Al Pacino every now and then
you're like oh he's - Al Pacino because
you can't direct that [ __ ]
unless you're a [ __ ] really good
director directors don't want to let
don't want to tell him they don't do
that can you do it this way because they
know opportunies gonna be like wow and
then you have to have an answer and
you're talking to the legend Al Pacino
De Niro these guys Walken is a great
example really really good but if you
[ __ ] not directing him it would just
be like wow wow uh and then you'd be
like okay just make it any sense dude
you gotta have someone you gotta have
someone to direct your life dude you
gotta have a wife or syrup partner
otherwise
[Music]
if Drake had a wife at that ride home
would be like what was it she'd be like
what what what is it what is it was the
chips with the dip thing 100% and she'd
be like what do you mean she would be
like why do you what is the chips with
the dip and he's explaining you know
like chips the dip the championship and
then the dip so I went on like it was
like if chips would that's when you
realize oh [ __ ] I'm an idiot because you
have to look at someone's face when
you're explaining it for real wives are
partners whatever the [ __ ] maybe you you
know [ __ ] dudes or whatever that's good
but you need to do to [ __ ] keep it
real I'll keep it 100 that's why keeping
it a hundred you got you're not let but
also you know you could still have a
wife and [ __ ] go nuts like Kanye I
guess but that's probably because Kim
Cade you know is probably yeah that's
the thing if you have another out to
lunch [ __ ] person on your team that's
the thing I guess it's about staying
grounded
I don't like figuring the [ __ ] out
before the show by the way I don't like
figuring it out I like talking it out
because we need to figure it out as a
cult because this is a cult dude but
staying positive in the limelight is
amazing staying positive and not losing
your [ __ ] mind like Keanu Reeves is
done now granted he's only like 52 but
there's this whole thing about doubling
down though now that like seems to work
because there's so many people out there
on the internet like Trump and everybody
just doubles the [ __ ] now look at just
see someone let any other time in
history
[ __ ] even ten years ago he would have
been like yeah [ __ ] up but he knows
there's enough people out there because
he sees them on the internet that he's
like no I really got [ __ ] jumped even
though you orchestrated the whole
goddamn thing and it was a Saddam
we know we know that he [ __ ] made it
up there's still conspiracy theorists
out there there's enough of them there's
hundreds of thousands of [ __ ]
that do this that think this and he's
just sitting there
nah he knows he's lying but he's like
nah didn't happen I got mugged and
jumped and because of that people like
even real people like Anthony Anderson
and [ __ ] will be like yeah dude I
believe him huh I got quest my thing is
what about the so much evidence it has
to be now though because it doesn't last
like everyone knows oh gee I didn't do
it I mean everyone knows OJ did it sorry
so so it has to be now if some [ __ ] goes
down now there's enough people to be on
your [ __ ] team because there's too
many people in the world it's just
there's too many people that's why I
think Santos was right you need to cut
the [ __ ] people in half
you saw endgame bro the first one I was
like I'm on Thanos this side look at all
these [ __ ] look at how many [ __ ]
first of all look at me
annoying superheroes there are the half
of those got to go and then some people
don't have superpowers and they're just
wheat their mouths to feed they got a go
dude if the population was cut in half
people like Jesse Simha let nobody would
believe him nobody would believe him
but there's too many people out there
finals for president dude
I'm chillin my babies I had a show
Saturday and I I had so much fun on
stage at the codis fool I did an episode
of match game I did two episodes a match
game I did that laughing last year but
they had me back I don't know why
because I [ __ ] said something like
[ __ ] guzzler the first time but anyway
they had me back and I wrote down [ __ ]
on my card and they have cameras above
you like Vegas and they're like Chris
you gotta rewrite that over the whole
loud thing and everyone was like [ __ ]
knowing so I guess you can say [ __ ] on
network TV so I I did match game it was
really fun
I met horatio sanz who was like my new
best friend loved that guy Kirstie Alley
and a bunch of other people that I
already knew but yeah Mike O'Shea was on
it
very cool and Alec Baldwin is just
killer at that [ __ ] he's so good at he
like there's the thing that a comedian
has that like were they're just they're
just always on ready to [ __ ] do a
joke and he he doesn't like if you don't
have that you're not a compete if you
don't if you're not a comedian you I've
never seen somebody that like has that
really unless you're like a strong like
if you do comedy sports or some [ __ ]
whatever they call that improv [ __ ] but
uh Alec Baldwin kind of has that like he
was he
he's just so confident and good and
quick with that [ __ ] he was really funny
anyway got a [ __ ] yeah watch match
game when I'm on in next year or
something whatever comes out dude I've
done so many guy I realize how many game
shows I don't know I think I'm on that
other one too to tell the truth coming
out and then another one I don't even
know like when I did them game shows are
like when you're when you do this [ __ ]
and they ask you to do a game show you
completely forget about because it's not
you the [ __ ] you want to do you just do
it because you like ought to be fun but
it's not like your goal in your career
so when they when they when they do when
you do a game show and then a year or
two later when it comes out you're like
oh [ __ ]
yeah I've done I've done a bunch of them
I don't even know which ones I've done
like I think I did to tell the truth
that's what they're to the Anderson
right I think that's a new one that's I
think this one with Anthony Anderson
yeah now I think so
yeah Anthony Anderson yeah I did that
one I only know by hosts and then I did
one with the other lady who I loved what
the [ __ ] was the game show called God
what the [ __ ] was that show called
no clue no [ __ ] clue
they're all reoccurring they always
trying to bring game shows back to
they'll let a game show be a hit for 10
years and then it'll go away and then
ten years later they'll be like this is
the reincarnation of [ __ ] [ __ ]
bubbles or whatever the hell it's called
and because they know was a hit I mean
how many times did they brought by match
game probably so many different times
and that's it Holly but when he shoots
all of them in like one week he should
solve him in five days he probably four
or five million dollars dude that's so
dope doing a game show being the host of
a game she'll be my nightmare though
they'll be my nightmare anytime you have
to say things that other people wrote
not as a character that's like death to
me like Ryan Seacrest job dude
I mean he's k-rock jogging by the
[ __ ] radio on the radio what he's
just talking that's that's one thing but
having to do American Idol being the
host of American Idol is I'd rather be a
[ __ ] crack [ __ ] cuz at least like
you're on the streets and you're like I
was kind of cool I could do it I want
yeah I have to suck dick every now and
then to get a [ __ ] kick but also at
least I get the key you know but having
to show up to work on ass in a suit and
just be like this next contestant like
dude get the [ __ ] out I swear to God our
other suck dick for cocaine then be like
this next contestant hails any time you
have to say the word Hales
put a [ __ ] dick in my ass instead for
crack dude
host worst job ever I'm a host here but
I don't I get to say whatever the [ __ ] I
want I'm
even really a house I'm just [ __ ]
bullshitting but anytime you got to be
like this next contestant hails from
Virginia let's listen to her do her sing
song rendition of lose yourself right
you're gonna lose yourself in the moment
yo knit row knit mitten
do you ever see that French guy come out
that blind French dude come out and sing
lose yourself that [ __ ] is so rockin
he's like blind and first of all I
didn't realize this but being blind
makes you look more French
I never realized this but it's the truth
if you google this guy blind lose
yourself first of all
he looks so French it's unreal dude
shape face nice glasses play it yeah
here we go
so blind lose yourself first of all the
fact that you can YouTube blind to lose
yourself is just means you know he comes
out they gotta walk him out because he's
blind his [ __ ] okay
that's his family the families are
always just [ __ ] so happy that they're
even there and that's so beautiful
now if he's blind why does he have
glasses on is what I want to know okay
so either he's tricking us or what the
[ __ ] going on but you know he's really
blind cuz he's got that one eye that's
like going out the other way right
looks like wonky titties you ever take a
good that's how dumb guys are you tell
you you have a girl take her shirt off
and then she's got titties and one
nipples looking like it's trying to get
away and you go like this alright well
[ __ ] it
you know I guess you can be my
girlfriend and wife haha looks don't
really matter that much though right
right that's what that looks looks on
the important thing all right it's
what's on the inside that that matters
right so right when you meet someone
like I mean I'm not superficial right
so you know if you meet it someone in
the opposite sex it's especially for a
guy doesn't matter right looks aren't
it's not what's important is what's
important on the inside right so it
doesn't matter if your face isn't
symmetrical or if you have your fat so
fat fat fat guy or girl it's all good
okay so so this guy sings lose yourself
and he comes out his parents are and
it's everyone's so excited you know and
he just dude if you're blind I didn't
know that if you're blind or if you have
an eye that goes off to the side you
look more French anyway this whole
[ __ ] whenever you see like the voice
French version of them it's so funny
seeing the different versions of the
people so he's playing the piano this
ripped this rips this guy is the [ __ ]
this is awesome
little bit of like
just like so you guys know in he's like
I'm gonna start off with that [ __ ]
high [ __ ] so you know it's a
just so you know I can [ __ ] be the
[ __ ] and then this rips dude I cried
watching this I'm a [ __ ]
sin secured the left
[Music]
so French what a key was so forgetting
so French
[Music]
little knowing with
start dancing kind of kicks away from
but whatever hey you know the hosts are
gonna like like I stopped but better
have its moment seemed to cure left
away
[Music]
setting even though it was a battle
but at the end part of this is this [ __ ]
[Music]
dude
by having to add afterwards but it's so
[ __ ] dope dude does that [ __ ] do it I
gotta get going on my [ __ ] high notes
man that's so dope dude
since secure laughs in the middle please
find this disappear laughs gotta find
this
[Music]
oh he knows he's killing it but he's
also knows he's still blind like that's
what that laugh was dude I love it bro
like he knows he's killing it but he's
like no no it's not that he's still
blind he knows he's coming in but he
doesn't know cuz he can't really see the
audience you know what I mean like he he
thinks he's killing it but that laugh is
a little insecure because he's like okay
but I know I can't see the people who
have straight faces right now dude that
dude rips that rips dude I love that guy
oh man how about people who would think
what I just said was offensive [ __ ] you
do it you know if I did that joke - that
guy he'd laugh and it wouldn't even
sound like that he really he left good
luck
[Music]
since secure card that guy rips dude I
think singing is so dumb you know
because it's like what are you doing
with your voice just relax start talking
it's all good but then when I got rips
like that it's so awesome man I remember
when I was a kid my mom would always be
like my mom put me in piano lessons for
a little bit and I was like ma this
sucks I don't want to do piano and she
was like you're gonna wish you did when
you were older I wish I could play the
[ __ ] piano and you know what dude I'm
here to say I don't I don't all right
when I was a kid I remember thinking of
my mom
now you're wrong and now that I'm 39 I'm
here to say as an adult I don't wish I
could where where the piano and I met
play and I'm gonna I know not but I'm
not fixing it I don't care I I don't
wish I could wear the piano I'm not
fixing that sentence I don't give a [ __ ]
dude not fixing it we need to stop
fixing our [ __ ] sentences for real
it'd be all whoops I meant this no I
didn't I meant what I [ __ ] [ __ ] up
said if somebody writes to it into 18
when the hot at 218 when the hot pocket
burns the roof of your mouth that's
pretty funny though he looking like a
mad scientist on his piano I love it
so funny dude the guy the guy right the
guy it's so funny sometimes how they
react like he literally just goes that's
how he does he just goes down and then
and the [ __ ] French is [ __ ] guy on
the on the on the back of the on the
chair he goes I guess it just goes bong
and he goes oh come on bro god I love
that dude I love the new style to this
already great song he made it his own
Bravo to be TBH i clicked just to ensure
he's cross-eyed i'm a bit too but not as
excessive then i realized though the
comments he's actually blind on top of
it he has a great voice hey okay cool
thanks bud thanks for the [ __ ]
wrap-up thanks for the [ __ ] report
dude dude the voice watching the foreign
voice i could do that all day they rip
oh here's another one blind another
blind one a blind guy singing you lose
yourself another one oh no he's not
blind as a blind audition got it
nevermind it's so weird to do a [ __ ]
rap song for the voice and actually rap
anyway what the [ __ ] is this crystally a
savage moment moments okay yeah but
whatever I was looking at Clips we got
to do a [ __ ] oh yeah we have an elder
dude this is awesome okay
elder where's the pronounce Kellie Lau
who made this thing
she did it for her class I saw this a
few weeks ago and she becoming a true
baby of the congratulations podcast a
complete guide to eldership and she just
I guess will retweet it or whatever you
know on our Twitter account but she did
all this [ __ ] like where she wrote down
gather your materials the first step in
becoming a true baby is making sure you
have all the required materials since
one of the tenants of the
congratulations on making things easy
possible office is that I've created a
short list of required materials for you
internet access a form of the podcast
room service iced americano all this
[ __ ] thick-skinned and a playful sense
of humor prepare yourself for your
journey to begin you need first acquire
access to congratulate squash is by
searching Google especially becoming a
true baby click the follow button it's
like it's [ __ ] really cute and funny
get the app watch comedy specials
incorrigible men on fire keep checking
back for new releases so funny anyway
will retweet this this is great but
Kelly Lao you're a now and elder for
this she did this for I think she said
she got an A+ or something if I remember
correctly so that's great and that's
cool that you used it to get an A+ and
move along in your life so well
congratulations we'll DM you the details
that's awesome was it gonna say oh yeah
I don't want to talk about that we'll
talk about that next time I guess that's
good we did an hour and I'm sweating
like a [ __ ] it's unbelievable
it's hard as hell right why is it so hot
as hell
oh man that's it I'm done I guess what
else that's it what do we have to say at
the end here where's the mouse I always
lose these things download the cash app
from the App Store or Google Play market
that's free go to Chris D'Elia calm and
get the stuff going for my you got to
get to the tickets for a fall later to
tour all right I still am doing new I
still haven't announced my thing yet
she's taking a while to get the deal
done but um I will announce it soon and
we got shows coming up go to Chris lead
calm and that's it my babies let's get
this log cabin thanks guys
[Music]